Our major partners, Sierra Nevada, Squaw Valley, Yosemite.
None of them were accepting new product. It got pushed back to the next season,
fall winter.
So that's basically six months of income that we don't have.
[Inaudible].
Dave Rubin and it's small business week here on the Rubin report.
Joining me today is Bryce Cooley co-owner of robe supply company
from Truckee, California, Bryce, welcome to the show.
Hey Dave, thanks a lot for having me really appreciate it.
I'm glad to be with you. Now.
I can tell you that I know that you guys make fine caps because you have sent us
a couple custom hats and, and we appreciate it.
My weekend at is the Sierra Nevada that you've sent us. Uh,
tell me a little bit about robe supply,
what you guys are doing and how you got into the biz.
Uh, I mean, pretty funny, our friend, Zach and Laura,
who we started the company with,
they did repping for a bunch of outdoor clothing companies, cool. Keen,
footwear, all that kind of stuff.
And so they had all these existing connections.
I was the youth pastor for several years,
and now I do kind of video audio stuff up at a different church.
And we just kind of talked he's very entrepreneurial and was like,
and just got us to buy into this vision of wanting to work for ourselves,
wanting to be able to provide for our families, all this kind of stuff,
just to provide for our kids, the most valuable people in our lives.
And so I hadn't even worn a hat before he talked to me about making hats.
And then he just kind of talked to me about the,
the margins are this and they're really good and you can make them for this and
sell them for this. And I didn't know, business. I was like,
those words sound good to me. And so he,
he got us to buy into it and it was right after we had our first child that we
actually started and got some connections based on their existing
connections they had with people and then moved slowly grown over the past
several years. And it's been a trial, but it's been good.
It's been real good.
Yeah. So as you know,
the reason that I wanted to do small business week is because people like you
guys are dealing with all sorts of crazy stuff that really nobody
expected from supply chain to sales, to everything else.
What are some of the struggles and maybe even some of the successes that you've
seen in the midst of the COVID situation?
Yeah, well,
I think Elon Musk said being an entrepreneur is like eating glass and staring
into the abyss of death. And I, I don't,
I don't think he had COVID in mind, but it definitely felt like that at times.
So our hats are actually produced in China.
So that adds a separate layer, uh, kind of on it.
So the first weeks of January, that's kind of when they shut down for awhile.
And so we were three weeks then,
and then there's a 14 day quarantine in their factories.
And so that was even longer. And so we're pushed back several weeks. Uh,
so right when we got all of our samples for spring, summer 20,
right now everything's shut down. And so our major partners,
uh, Sierra Nevada, Squaw Valley Yosemite,
none of them were accepting new product. It got pushed back to the next season,
fall winter.
So that's basically six months of income that we don't have.
Uh, and you know,
luckily we're in a business where we're not going month to month, we get paid,
you know, when purchase orders come in and all that.
And so we just really cut back a lot of stuff in and were able
to get PPP and Eid L after a lot of headache,
we're able to get some of that stuff to kind of help carry us. But it,
we were thinking we're going to have to stop getting paid in the next month
or two and all of that kind of stuff. And,
and we had to bring on new clients as well to try to make up for the fact that
we're now missing six months of income.
Can you talk a little bit about the PP headache? Because it was like, you know,
I'm a small business owner too, and,
and we applied for it and then we got it and then they changed the rules.
And then there was another rule change and I had to have a big sit-down with my
business managers and, and the whole thing. Um, what,
what was that like for you guys and how desperate it sounds like,
sounds like you might've been okay without it, but you you're, you know,
it helps, right?
Yeah. So we, we would have been okay for a short time, without it,
basically we could have made it kind of through the lockdown,
but then right after that, all of our production money, all of our payroll,
all of that would have had to stop and we'd have to just kind of work for free
until, uh, production orders started coming in.
So ultimately we reached out to our bank and we said like, okay,
can we put this in now? They're like, well, you know,
there's so many things coming in, let's wait until this of the other thing.
And we're like, we really need to do it now.
And so we ended up missing the first loan. They ran out of money by the time,
uh, they actually got it through or whatever.
And so then we had to refill everything out again. Uh,
and finally we got in on the tail end of the second one.
So that was a huge blessing. You know,
I don't love like getting handouts or whatever,
but it was a blessing door to keep our small staff getting paid through this and
allowing them to provide for their families. That was huge for us.
So since you mentioned being a youth pastor, uh, before all this,
can you talk about just as a,
as a small business owner sort of owning and controlling your destiny and,
and having to navigate, Oh,
these things that happen out of nowhere that you didn't expect sort of how that
sort of, you know, how that sort of encompasses your, your philosophy around?
Oh man. Well,
I would say the Christian faith definitely kind of points out that unexpected
things happen and, you know,
there's this idea of a peace that transcends all understanding. So, you know,
ultimately we have trusted God through this.
Like this is a crazy situation for everyone to be in and it just hit everyone.
And even when I was kinda in my moment, freaking out, or my wife was,
or Zach was, we were kind of able to balance like, no, I think we're,
we're going to be okay. And, you know,
just kinda work through that and just praying would kind of calm me
down and just relax me also working my butt off to try to get new clients
and then getting positive feedback that also helped. Uh, we're actually,
this is kind of fun. We're currently in development with Tesla,
maybe making some stuff for them, which would be a huge, wow.
Like that'd be a huge blessing, but you know, I wanna get my hopes up,
but pretty excited about that. But, uh, uh, so our,
our faith really kind of gave us peace in that.
And as far as the way that we do our business, we really try to do it ethically.
The factory is fair trade.
We try to wherever we can be eco-conscious and use recyclable materials and
all that kind of stuff where it's possible. We try to,
we try to give the best quality that we can to the people we
customize hats for.
Yeah. And you guys really do make a great hat. Like I've got,
I got about 30 hats in my closet. You guys really do make a great hat. Uh,
so I gotta ask you this from once from,
from one small business guy in California,
to another small business guy in California,
you have any struggles doing business in California.
We're paying a lot in taxes.
There's all sorts of red tape and regulations and the rest of it.
I always find people when, when I talk about this, people always say, well,
Dave, you're doing business in California. What do you expect?
What do you make of that?
Yeah. Uh, and this is the one time I'll give my dad, uh,
ribbing. My dad works in the assembly and I'm like, dad,
you're killing me with this business stuff. You know, sorry.
I th I throw it to him and he he's aware of it. Yeah. I mean,
taxes are high and it makes it difficult to bring on employees and all of that
kind of stuff. I mean, the, the thing that I've just kind of processed through.
It's like we live in a high tech state, but everyone that I love is here.
So I need to decide, what do I want to sacrifice?
Do I want to sacrifice the relationships to bring in some more money or do I
want to sacrifice money to stay around relationships?
Let my girls be near their grandparents and their cousins and their aunts and
uncles and all that kind of stuff. So, yeah,
it is very difficult owning a business in California, but you know,
th this is where we're at right now. We might be moving up to Eldorado County.
God-willing uh, so w my self and my wife live in Sacramento,
Beth, Zach and Laura live in Truckee.
And so we kind of telework even before all of this.
Yeah. Uh, before we wrap up, uh,
I want to give you a full-on chance to promote the hell out of your hats right
now. Let's see, go into full salesmen mode right now, man, here you go.
Take it away.
All right, Zach. Sorry if I don't do well, but, uh, we,
we have been working with some awesome people for a long time. Sierra,
Nevada brewing squad Valley, all of that stuff. Uh,
we are for the first time,
I believe the store is going live at the beginning of July.
We're going to make our own row branded hats for the first time ever.
We've always been doing private label, custom headwear.
Now we're going to actually do some of our own with our own hat on it.
So if you want to support two families who are just trying to love people
and serve the community and do all of that kind of stuff,
like it would be a huge blessing to us. If you actually have a company,
we have minimums of 576 per style,
but if you want some really good quality hats that lasts, come to us,
shoot me an email or Instagram is at Rove supply. You can shoot me an email
bryce@rofesupply.com and I'd be glad to hook you up.
And we can kind of start that conversation.
So really appreciate the time to do this, Dave, and just, it means a lot.
Thank you.
The, I think your partner is going to be proud of the sales pitch. And for real,
I'm telling you, I got a ton of hats, but you guys, you guys make a real hat.
Like it, doesn't kind of collapse on you or, you know,
you put some hats on and then you can feel that they're just not that well.
Like you can see it on your head. It's Primo quality stuff.
I appreciate your support.
You're a member of the Rubin report community as well. And, uh,
one of these days when, when people actually see each other again,
I'll get up to Northern Cali and okay.
Yeah. I was supposed to see in San Francisco, but that all, you know,
then everything got all shut down. So yeah. Hey, when you need hats,
let us know, man.
Right on. All right. Thanks Bryce. And it is [inaudible] road, supply.com,
right?
Yeah. Roof supply.com and at Rose supply and Instagram. All right,
thanks so much, man. Have a great day.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.